bon
[Musique]
il
ici un sapin baumier car vie sauvage
peupliers beaumier mérite mon mieux la
compagnie voyageuse label jaune hier et
john dragoon et le thé les mois à sainte
anne des monts
le chocolatier carl pelletier et sa
fille paul concocte de délicieuses
bouchées aux saveurs du terroir
j'aimerais que vous poussez le piémont
me pour qu'on se met en bouche une
expérience de marche en forêt
[Musique]
c'est une explosion en bouche c'est
quelques bouchées donc il faut que ça
explose obstinément c'est ça sapin
baumier thé des bois car riz sauvage des
arômes singulier à découvrir dans des
chocolats forestier le cueilleur de ses
saveurs c'est gérard mathar un expert du
terroir forestier gaspésien je lui ai
donné des échantillons et puis bon petit
à petit voilà il a essayé il a aimé puis
une fois que tu as osé franchir le pas
dans le fond était plus ouvert que passe
quand même la femme que quelqu'un qui
soit beige arrivent au québec récolte
des choses d'ici
et puis il me dit acs a fait sa plage
essai puis ça marche et les choses qui a
répété revoyons dont enfin je peux
mettre un chocolat aux parfums gaspésien
autour de sa ferme près de gaspé dans sa
forêt il récolte depuis une quinzaine
d'années des dizaines de plantes
aromatiques sauvages et les vend à des
restaurateurs ou en épicerie fine
mais il inspire aussi les artisans de la
péninsule mais tous avaient déjà d'
avance que certains des produits aller à
lèvres de chocolat bah c'est sûr j'ai
aimé les utiliser dans les desserts j'ai
jamais eu non plus d'à priori sur une
épice qui n'iraient jamais avec simple
j'essaye puis des fois c'est pas bon du
tout mais j'essaye tu vois donc j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de tests à la maison
moi mon but c'est pas cueilli rennais
peut se dire tiens ça c'est comme de la
vanille c'est de la famille ça peut te
faire passer à sa oui mais moi je
cherche pas à remplacer le point sauve
un jeu va remplacer tel poivre
aromatiques ou non si c'est des choses
qui sont dans la même gamme mettons de
goût etc
mais c'est pas la même chose
[Musique]
de l'autre côté la péninsule à cap
d'espoir c'est une bande d'amis qui a
décidé de fonder une distillerie dans un
lieu insolite
mathieu fleury et 6 à midi ch'ti du
grand la bouteille un jean unique 100 %
québécois notre idée c'était vraiment de
prendre les saveurs de notre région et
de les mettre en bouteille donc les
herbes folles en fait c'est un jean qui
est aromatisée avec une dizaine d herbes
de fleurs de racines qui sont toutes des
plantes sauvages de la gaspésie et dans
nos recherches évidemment le nom de
gérard est sorti assez rapidement 11 35
gérard c'est une sommité en la matière
on récolte pour eux un certain nombre de
choses eux ont fait leur expérimentation
je pense qu'ils savaient déjà vers où il
s'en allait pousser et il connaissait
déjà ça pas mal
parmi ces herbes folles la baie de
genièvre bien sûr mais aussi du poivre
crispé du quart dit sauvage de la fleur
d'épilogues de la tanaisie et de
l'armoise d'avoir cette proximité lors
de la nature mais ça nous inspire dans
ce qu'on fait
ici un plan numérique beaumier on ne
verra pas et chatons parce qu'on est
trop tôt ici les feuilles peuvent aussi
utiliser un appareil en tête- c'est ça
quand même encore cette petite odeur de
camphre wind arômes et est présent déjà
évidemment ça pousse au bord des lacs
sont impuissants dans lequel un chaton
qui est très très aromatique
je le sens jusqu'ici citronnée ses
manteaux les camps free c'est très fort
en goût fait pour médecins de chocolat
c'est parfait ici
sapin baumier il est fou ce qu'on va
récolter qui sont plus verts tendres qui
commence juste à sortir donc tout ceci
va être récoltés mis à sécher puis
starhome sucre et barbe à papa
oui qu'elles contiennent va vraiment
sortir ça c'est délicieux et ça c'est
vraiment plus un chocolat ou pour
prendre le temps de déguster parce que
ça nous avait d'ailleurs c'est ma
gaspésie rebouché tu peux goûter pour te
donner une idée je reconnais le petit
goût qu'on avait le chocolat oui voilà
il est là vraiment assure c'était le bon
produit et c'est ça
[Musique]